hey guys it's Justine and today we are
going to be doing a painting and not
just any painting we're going to be
following a Bob Ross tutorial these have
been a really fun trends and I've been
enjoying watching a bunch of people do
these and do them sort of in their own
style like for Zanna she did this
incredible painting with icing so I was
inspired to do one on the iPad we're
gonna be using procreate today I haven't
really used this app very much but
recently in the past couple of weeks
I've been messing around with it so that
I can be familiar with brushes and
colors and kind of just know the
interface a little bit but that's all
that we're gonna do this is the bob ross
ocean sunset this is season 10 episode
10 my grandmother was a painter so she
used to always make me do illustrations
and paintings and stuff when I was
younger and we would watch bob ross
together and do watercolors and this is
gonna be so much fun to do I don't know
what's gonna happen I hope that it turns
out well I guess I'll stop talking let's
start the tutorial hey glad to see you
again a day you ready to a fantastic
season I won't be ready yet I don't have
my colors set up yet like I've got a lot
of things happening okay so I need a
gray he's got a pause like I don't even
know my colors I'll have my brushes
prepped or anything I'm gonna do I think
in the painting I'm probably gonna go
with gistic don't know nice oil
it sounds great it's that good the
screaming a little doing a good job
gasps he's probably got some white so
I'll just throw in some of the white oh
shoot so now that he's getting into some
yellow I'm not ready for that
[Music]
yellow here I'm super into layers so I
will probably have a million layers and
this is the one terabyte iPad 2 so I can
pretty much make as many layers as I
want better right over here he says
horizon okay well Bob his blending is
way better than mine problem is this
it's it's not quite accurate because I
don't have the exact brushes that he has
and beat the devil Adam beat the devil
okay cuz like he's doing a little bit of
purple-ish so I'm gonna just do that as
well well these are clouds I think I
might need a different brush like beauty
with very gently he says oh this
actually this is a nice brush this is
actually working on quite well
some circular strokes super into
circular strokes this is actually really
fun I love doing like oh that looks good
I am an artist I'm a freaking artist
it doesn't look good don't get too
excited but you could add like overlay
I'm like one box it's getting there
we've got got some things to do just got
it had a little of my own Flair because
Bob his iPad wasn't around when you were
around okay what are you doing now
you're putting some dark blue over there
who the hell is actually really good I
should get more into watercolor but I
don't feel like that brush that's the
problem they don't know like what
brushes to use he's doing all kinds of
things and I can't catch up oh gosh
we've made not much progress
there and he's got a little more here
[Music]
blend this this is stressful I don't
know what it was it was like to be Bob
Ross but he's really good at his job
I was watching like some conspiracy
theory Bob Ross videos the other day I
just don't know what to do fan brush you
can add some little streakers it was a
little straighter super he said we're
making a big decision I'm not ready
we're doing over how we're doing the
wave we're getting into the wave like in
this that okay looks like we've got that
done they'll agree and seascapes okay
good to note everything he's doing is
he's just he's a perfect perfect man
what are you using purple a purplish hmm
we need darker he's like there's all
kinds of things back here but like how
do I make those things we're gonna do
another layer because I don't trust
myself pretty happy with that but that's
where all this is they don't even have
to clean my brushes it just just me just
do it guess I can zoom in and really get
some detail where's that layer is this
over here is that you is you I'm finally
figuring out what brushes to use so this
is all just really working out nicely
except for this right here this little
piece is just bugging me I have a lot
more to do we're 16 minutes and 34
seconds in to the tutorial this is where
we're at so far it's looking just okay
now that I'm like figuring out my
brushes and stuff this is gonna make a
big difference when I actually start
working on this
oh no he's moved on he's moved on I
haven't even done the last step that's
not good brush that's not the brush I
need that's not the person they need is
that what I want not sure I'm gonna zoom
in I'm gonna zoom in and really get in
there I think that's kind of what he was
doing
yellow what why are you using that now
I'm confused thinking may have done a
little too much like what did you just
do some foam okay okay that looks bad
hums bad just leave just delete
everything
Bob why does mine look like Josh do you
want to keep this color as pure as you
can what are you saying
you're just you're saying a lot of
things but look at that splash Wow Bom
I see what you're doing now yeah but his
looks better
and I know you're going too fast you're
going too fast we're not ready this is
so fun
right absolutely does not look like that
absolutely not what I have going on here
I'm more of an abstract artist I just
can't work in these conditions now what
do you want me to do all right now what
don't everything sucks so I'm working a
little bit more on this I'm starting to
get frustrated I think we've been
filming for like an hour now this
tutorial is only 26 minutes but I've
been double that but now that I've kind
of developed with some sort of style I
kind of want to go back and redo the sky
layer below that stoat Elise I know
worries okay thank you bye so Skye so
we're working on the sky a little bit
I'm just gonna kind of merge all of
these things together so that I can
really just I'm not sure I'm not sure
what I'm doing but we're gonna duplicate
this layer oh wow this just changed the
game it's never to go in and just get a
nice little nice little something all
right this is gonna be something that
you're gonna want to print out you're
gonna want to make it up into a green
card for your family you're gonna vote
mom I made you something
dad look at this grandma made this for
you you're gonna be like that's trash
get this out of my house that's trash
looks still looks better but I am using
an iPad and Bob he's doing some more
stuff I've enjoyed it have you enjoyed
it I've had a lovely time oh I need to
add okay so I gotta add some highlights
to these rocks because that's something
that I did not do I think I'm running
low on ink
I keep getting post meets notifications
because basically that's every time I
shoot a video it ends up just being me
waiting for both Oh
are they here yet I just need that
yellow to go away cuz it's not really
that into you ever just gonna have to
deal with it
like I think that's just what its gonna
be for one more thing to salvage of this
cuz it looks like he did like something
like all up in here now just ruined
everything I quit I quit I quit I quit I
quit okay I'm gonna delete this layer
I'm just gonna forget that it even
happened this is what we're gonna deal
with this is my final piece let me sign
it I'm signing my name to it and I'm
just gonna call it quits there it is my
art my art is done
I am completed my task okay so I could
probably do this for several more hours
but I need to stop myself but let me
show you what I have done this is my
final masterpiece in comparison to the
Bob Ross is done I don't know how I feel
about it I feel like there's a lot more
that I want to do to it thank you guys
so much for watching I hope you guys
enjoyed this video I really had a great
time doing this I did get a little bit
frustrated at some point because I've
never really used procreate that much so
there was a bit of a learning curve but
if you guys have used it before please
leave some tips below I would love to
hear more from you guys and if you'd
like to see me do another video like
this let me know what you'd like to see
me do leave those also in the comments
below and I'll see you guys in my next
video
if you haven't subscribed already be
sure to hit subscribe and like the video
if you liked it and if you didn't like
it
just hit like anyway and just make my
I feel better Bob Ross you're a legend
[Music]